when designing a lair for a conflict you
might have to pick do you want a 1x3
filter or a three by three or a five by
five or do you want a pulling layer what
the inception that Network does is it
says why should do them all and this
makes the network architecture more
complicated but it also works remarkably
well let's see how this works let's say
for the sake of example that you have
input is a 28 by 28 by 192 dimensional
volume so what the inception network or
what an inception layer says is instead
of choosing what filter size you want in
a conflate
do you want a convolutional layer or
pooling layer let's do them all so one
of you can use a one by one convolution
and that will output a 28 by 28 by
something let's say 28 by 28 by 64
output and you just have a volume there
but maybe you also want to try a 3 by 3
and that might output a tawny by 28 by
128 and then what you do is just stack
up this second volume next to the first
volume and to make the dimensions match
up let's make this a same convolution so
the output dimension is still 28 by 28
same as the input dimension in terms of
height and width but 28 by 28 by in this
example 128 and maybe you might say well
I want to hatch my bed's maybe a 5 by 5
filter works better so let's do that too
and have that to output a 28 by 28 by 32
and again you use the same convolution
to keep the dimensions the same and
maybe you don't want to convolutional
there let's apply pooling and that has
some other output and let's stack that
up as well and here pulling outputs to
neat by 28 by 32 now in order to make
all the dimensions match you actually
need to use padding from
fooling so this is an unusual form of
polling because if you want the input to
have higher than worth twenty by twenty
eight and have the output you know match
the dimension everything else also by 28
by 28 then you need to use same padding
as well as the strata one for pooling so
this detail might seem a bit funny to
you now but let's let's keep going and
we'll make this all work later but with
a inception module like this you can
input some volume and output in this
case I guess if you add up all these
numbers 32 plus 32 plus 128 plus 64
that's equal to 2 5 6 so you will have 1
Inception module input 28 by 28 by 129
and output 28 by 28 by 256 and this is
the heart of the inception Network which
is due to Christians agony wanly
orienting TRPs I mean Scott lead
Dragomir Angela Dmitri Orhan Vincent and
cook and Andrew ramen average and the
basic idea is that instead of you
needing to pick one of these filter
sizes or pooling you want and committing
to that you can do them all and just
concatenate all the outputs and let the
network learn whatever parameters it
wants to use whatever combinations of
these filter sizes it wants now it turns
out that there's a problem with the
inception there as we've described it
here which is computational cost on the
next slide let's figure out what's the
computational cost of this 5x5 filter
resulting in this block over here so
just focusing on the 5x5 pot on the
previous slide we had as input a 28 8 by
20 by 192 block and you implement a 5 by
5 same convolution or 32 filters to
output 28 by 28 by 32 on their previous
slide I had drawn this as a thin purple
slice so I'm just I draw this as a more
normal looking blue block here so let's
look at
computational cost of outputting this 20
by 20 by 32 so you have 32 filters
because the output has 32 channels and
each filter is going to be 5 by 5 by 192
and so the output size is 20 by 20 by 32
and so you need to compute Tony by 28 by
32 numbers and for each of them you need
to do you know this many multiplications
right 5 by 5 by 192 so the total number
multiplies you need is the number of
multiplies you need to compute each of
the output values times the number of
output values you need to compute and if
you multiply out all these numbers this
is equal to 120 million and so while you
can do 120 million multiplies on the
modern computer this is still a pretty
expensive operation on the next line you
see how using the idea of one-by-one
convolutions which you learned about in
the previous video you'd be able to
reduce the computational cost by about a
factor of 10 to go from about 120
million multiplies to about one tenth of
that so please remember the number 120
so you can compare it with what you see
on the next slide hundred twenty million
here's an alternative architecture for
inputting to an 8 by 20 by 192 and
outputting to an 8 by 20 by 32 which is
following your going to input the volume
use a 1 by 1 convolution to reduce the
volume to a 16 channels instead of 192
channels and then on this much smaller
volume run your 5 by 5 convolution to
give you your final output so notice the
input and output dimensions are still
the same you input Tony by 20 but 182
and output Tony by 20 by 32 same as the
previous slide but what we've done is
we're taking this huge volley we had on
the left and we'll shrunk it to
this much smaller intermediate volume
which is only has 16 instead of hundred
ninety-two channels
sometimes this is called a bottleneck
there all right I guess because a
bottleneck is usually the smallest part
of something right so I guess if you
have a glass bottle that looks like this
then you know this is Vegas where the
core goes then the bottleneck is the
smallest part of this bottle so the same
way the bottleneck layer is the smallest
part of this network we shrink the
representation before increasing the
size again now let's look at the
computational cost involved to apply
this one-by-one convolution we have 16
filters each of the filters is going to
be of dimension 1 by 1 by 192 this 192
matches that 192 and so the cost of
computing this 20 by 20 by 16 volume is
going to be well you need this many
outputs and for each of them you need to
do
192 multiplications I could have written
1 times 1/5 times 192 right this is this
and if you multiply this out this is 2.4
under the n is about 2.4 million how
about the second so that's the cost of
this first convolutional layer the cost
of this second convolutional layer will
be that well you have this many outputs
so 20 by 28 by 32 and then for each of
the outputs you have to apply a 5 by 5
by 16 dimensional filter and so 5 by 5
by 16 and you multiply that out is equal
to 10.0 and so the total number of
multiplications you need to do is the
sum of those which is twelve point four
million multiplications and you compare
this with what we had on the previous
slide you reduce the computational cost
from about 120 million
flies down to about one tenth of that to
twelve point four million
multiplications oh and the number of
additions you need to do is about very
similar to the number of multiplications
you need to do so that's why I'm just
counting the number of multiplications
so to summarize if you're building a
layer of a new network and you don't
want to have to decide do you want a one
by one or three by three or five by five
were pooling layer the inception module
lets you say let's do them all and let's
concatenate the results and then we ran
to the problem of computational cost and
which you saw here was how using a one
by one convolution you can create this
bottleneck layer thereby reducing the
computational cost significantly now you
might be wondering does shrinking down
the representation size so dramatic does
it hurt the performance of your neural
network it turns out that so long as you
implement this bottleneck layer so the
proven reason you can string down the
representation size significantly and it
doesn't seem to hurt the performance but
saves you a lot of computation so this
is the key of the these are the key
ideas of the inception module let's put
them together and in the next video show
you what the full inception network
looks like